[Música]
después de mucho escuchar y de mucho
escuchar y de mucho compartir con
docentes
pensábamos cuál es la potencia grande
que tiene un docente el poder
maravilloso que tiene un docente en que
se expresa y armamos alguna vez una
frase que dice
hacerse inolvidables
todos nosotros tenemos recuerdos de
algún docente o de varios que alguna vez
nos dijeron una frasecita nos dijeron un
llevo un gesto
una recomendación un reto una actitud
que los marcó para siempre una lucecita
que duró para siempre
yo recuerdo
una noche cálida no sé si de primavera o
de otoño
en córdoba en el hospital san roque esos
hospitales viejos
en una aula tipo anfiteatro
última materia de la carrera clínica
médica
se presenta un profesor que yo lo
conocía y nos dice
contra que luchamos los médicos
y un apurado los ganó a todos y dice
contra la muerte
nos quedamos todo hasta en dicho hecho
es con la respuesta de nuestro compañero
todos chochos - el profesor
contra la muerte
no aprendieron nada
la muerte gana siempre que no se mueve
muchachos nosotros luchamos contra el
sufrimiento de la gente
y otro un poco después
dijo algo parecido dijo los médicos en
tanto un médico sobre la vida y la
muerte no sabemos nada
nosotros sabemos algo sobre algunas
enfermedades
dejando clarito que sobre otras no
sabemos nada y sobre ninguna sabemos
todos
esas dos cosas no me las pude más
olvidar toda la carrera de médico mi
trayectoria mi hacer mi pensar tuvo que
ver con mantenerme presente con estos
dos conceptos es contra el sufrimiento
y ojo no no es desde el pedestal de la
suprema sabiduría es desde la intención
de cuidar ser cuidadores eso significa
médico cuidador
pero cuando vas analizando tu proceder
médico y analizadas los tratamientos que
puedes hacer y las estrategias
terapéuticas que se van desarrollando te
preguntas qué pregunta este punto de
sufrimiento esto va bien contra el
sufrimiento
hay algunos datos que ponen nerviosos
una persona
gasta en salud una cantidad de dinero
durante su vida
pero los últimos 10 días gasta el triple
de lo que gastó todo el resto el 75 por
ciento de lo que gasta en su salud los
gaste los últimos 15 días digamos lo
gasta para morirse
no parece estar bien bien desparramado
el recurso no parece ser contra el
sufrimiento el asunto parece que nos
desesperamos con la muerte
pero bueno así funciona así estamos
en la sociedad y saberes que construimos
entre todos hay saberes que nos indican
cómo manejarnos qué es lo que creemos
que es lo que valíamos
y aparecen nuestras formas de trabajo de
expresión
por ejemplo nosotros decimos calidad de
vida y todos sabemos que en calidad de
vida
televisores trabajan de vacaciones
largas lejos
casas amplia bien calefaccionada bien en
este aireadas ropa fina calidad de vida
celulares
seguridad es el otro tema todos queremos
estar seguros en la vida quiero sentirme
seguro tranquilo y que seguridad bueno
este
poco de dinero un trabajo una casa
y la pregunta que siempre va es en el
análisis y esto es válido esto funciona
esto funciona esto funciona bien la
calidad de vida de los televisores esto
es verdad es verdad es la calidad de
vida y la seguridad sería esto del
trabajo y me acuerdo de josecito a mí me
viene concedido los éxitos tenía un
excelente trabajo una excelente casa un
excelente auto se llevamos bárbaro con
el jefe y era amigo del dueño último
éste tenía tenía dinero tenía una
prepaga de las máscaras tenía un
avión-ambulancia que el abonado tenía al
servicio de emergencias hasta su
domicilio comía comida de nutricionista
tenía un gimnasio montado en el garaje
se hidrata va mucho dormía las horas que
correspondían y un día después de
almorzar
se fue dormido la siesta y como dijo un
hijo mío pues todo vivo y despertó
puesto
no podría usar de descuento de farmacia
pero murió seguro
será verdad todo eso es eso lo que
tenemos que buscar y salud salud también
es un lineal no hay discusión le duele
algo voy al médico me dio un remedio
de lo que cobran que algo me dé
y un saber y vamos a ver si queremos eso
y recibimos eso y recibimos esto
y volvemos con los datos y el
sufrimiento estamos todos bien viniendo
el 65% de los sufrimientos que llevan
una persona a un médico son ambientales
tienen que ver con cómo vive dónde vive
con quién vive
tiene voz potable tiene cloacas tiene
trabajo tiene un buen jefe la señora
está bien el trataría de la señora este
vive asignado con cuatro familias cinco
hijos una sola habitación este sufre
mucho calor mucho frío tiene hábitos
tóxicos fuma mucho más rápido con la
moto
un 15% casi de los problemas que nos
llevan al médico tienen que ver con la
genética
ni siquiera son enfermedades cosas
genéticas cosas que están determinadas
en nuestro plano que nos hacen
particulares que nos dan ciertas
características
solamente podríamos decir que el 15% de
las afecciones que llevan a la gente al
médico sí o sí debieran ser respondidas
con un medicación a eso sí nosotros les
damos medicamentos pero no todos se
llevan algo en nosotros medicalizado y
medicamentos hasta los duelos todo
cualquier cosa
pero claro hay un saber que lo pide y no
saber que lo produce como respuesta
y será verdad a mí me parece que la
verdad a mí decir la verdad es que los
televisores son calidad de vida y que la
gente está segura porque tiene los
graves social los dique y que quieren la
salud tiene que ver con ir al medio que
te dé un remedio
pero gastamos tanto dinero en remedios
remedios la inversión que se hace el
público de la obra social de los
financiadores en comprar soluciones en
cajitas en botellita en inyectables si
son mejores las cajitas más caro
remedios y los más caros de ese más
bueno
y bueno sabemos
sabemos sabemos de neurotransmisores
químicos quien no sabe serotonina
antidepresivos
neurociencias
siempre luchado porque los médicos
escuchen a la gente la gente tiene mucho
saber sobre todo sobre ellos a lo que
les pasa en ellos hay un saber muy
grande en la gente sobre lo que le pasa
pero eso no nos transforma en médicos
saben sobre su sufrimiento y hay que
escucharlos pero ahora la gente no va al
médico sin google primero como antes te
lo ocultaba te hacía preguntas
inteligentes y los oídos no sacaba
y todo eso como si estamos
esto que cuento ahora si no fuera
trágico también sería gracioso
una señora de 43 años
desgreñados los pelos y la postura
triste llorosa llega el seductor
no tengo
lo que antes me gustaba ya no me gusta
no salgo de la cama y encima no puedo
dormir
no tengo interés a futuro no tengo
planes ya no todo el tiempo no me mire
la serotonina
número antidepresivo
recuerda un poquito de su vida doctor
qué quieres
teme su vida conocer su historia pero
usted tiene más datos necesita para
saber estoy depresiva
cuénteme un poquito
hace 23 años que estoy casada hace 22
que me faltan el respeto
me maltrataba psicológicamente
económicamente me controlan las dominan
me desprecio se desvalorizan y
y me pegan
y yo me quedo pensando y la miro y en
mirada mía dice esta pregunta dice la
mirada ya no te parece que si yo tengo
un antidepresivo tu marido te deja
agregar
ella puede creer eso porque si no le
deja de pegar con él porque pastilla de
levantar el ánimo
pero esa cultura es lo que hemos armado
en lo que todos sabemos es así ahora es
así
será verdad no sólo me parece falso me
parece peligroso porque mientras gasto
dinero y tiempo y esfuerzo ilusión en
establecer y luchar por modelos de
tratamientos que no me van a dar una
solución a mi sufrimiento no hago todo
el otro lo que si podría hacer para
solucionar el problema pero estamos como
que la felicidad la seguridad la salud
el disfrute viene de afuera para adentro
de afuera para adentro en cajitas lindas
mejor adornada más caro
y yo me pregunto
pensemos en el hombre de las cavernas
y pensemos ahora
ha pasado mucho tiempo ha pasado mucha
agua
nos hemos transformado en seres
diferentes más ricos más complejos hemos
desarrollado el arte la ciencia el
deporte la filosofía
algo pasó que nos cambio y que nos trajo
hasta aquí y eso qué pasó no estaba
afuera el hombre de las cavernas no
encontró allí afuera el camino para
venir hasta aquí afuera estaban las
naranjas las manzanas las cosas que
empezó a entender que podía comer las
que eran venenosas los animales que
podían cazar y los otros que mordían
fuerte
las cuevas donde guarecerse eso había en
el afuera como hizo desde afuera llegar
aquí
adentro
y yo allí adentro
encontró cosas que lo hacían
ser alguien encontró cosas que lo hacían
personas que no podía estar sin ellas
que sin ella no había vida o no había
dignidad en esta vida y le llamo
necesidades se dio cuenta que el ser
humano es un ser de necesidades
y a partir de comprobar eso a partir de
aprender qué es una cosa es me gustaría
y otra cosa es necesito
porque de esas necesidades comprendió
que nacían sus derechos
y cuando pudo empatizar
cuando pudo ponerse frente al prójimo y
entender que en el otro lado pasaba lo
mismo que desde adentro pasaba lo mismo
que había también necesidades y por lo
tanto había también derechos empezó a
construir sociedad grupo empezó a
complejizar empezó a armar el colectivo
cuando pudo comprender que forma parte
de una cadena solidaria que se necesitan
mutuamente donde cada pieza es
importante donde cada pieza es un
eslabón de una cadena muy grande es un
una parte de una red muy compleja
cuando aprendió eso que pudo crecer
y pudo salir hacia el afuera
cuando el ser pudo entonces ver en el
otro a un igual cuando pudo entender que
esos esas necesidades esos miedos esos
anhelos esos yo estaban también en el
otro entonces pude iniciar ese camino ya
que estamos en una época donde se
vanagloria tanto a la aventura y a las
cosas empezó el camino más difícil y más
atemorizante que un hombre puede
emprender
es el viaje del interior
el viaje hacia el interior de uno mismo
nos lleva a dejar de sentirnos maradona
superman y entender lo que podemos y lo
que no podemos lo que aprendimos y lo
que no aprendimos lo que sabemos y lo
que no sabemos
y allí entonces el hombre pudo decir
calidad de vida calidad de vida es vivir
en un mundo donde valga la pena vivir
seguridad no necesito seguridad no
existe la seguridad seguro seguro que
soy yo seguro
y tengo que aprender a surfear la vida
esa dinámica de olas que van y que
vienen
y que me hacen crecer y que me hacen
aprender salud
salvo no puede ser un remedio un sabio
argentino hace 50 años dijo frente a las
enfermedades que produce la pobreza la
miseria y el infortunio social de los
pueblos los microbios como causa de las
pobres causas
otro mucho más cerca de nuestro tiempo
dijo salud salud es dominar y enfrentar
desarrollar capacidades frente a lo que
limita nuestra vida y esto me gustaría
que fuera también argentino por el
catalán se juntaron los médicos y los
antropólogos que es la salud salud es la
capacidad de ser libre feliz y solidario
si puedo optar si puedo optar y hacerme
cargo de lo que dijo si puedo ser feliz
que nuevo una lotería ser feliz es una
producción por decisión si puedo
entenderme solidariamente responsable de
lo que hagamos con nuestras vidas
entonces soy sano tenga o no un tumor
tenga o no poco mucho tiempo de vida
todos los bólidos pero si tengo este
físicas o la genética
y no sé ser feliz y no sé que soy
responsable
y solidario no puedo elegir libremente
estoy sano
la calidad de vida es la dignidad de la
vida la salud es una actitud hacia el
otro donde el otro me importa yo le
importo y podemos buscar las verdaderas
causas de lo que nos pasa el camino es
tan largo que hemos emprendido desde las
cavernas hasta aquí queremos que sea
mucho mucho más largo ese camino está
adentro y está mucho más cerca del
corazón que de la cabeza pero eso sería
otra charla
[Aplausos]
[Música]